[Music] We Have
Seen The Different Kinds of Decimal
Numbers They Are Broadly Classified Into
Terminating Decimals and Non Terminating
Decimals Terminating Decimals Are the Ones
That Don't Go On Forever and Non
Terminating Decimals as the Word Suggests
And Do
Not
Terminate Non terminating decimal numbers are
classified into two types recurring and
non recurring The non terminating decimals are called recurring if there is a
set of
digits after the decimal point that repeats for
ever and they are called non recurring if there are
no sets  Of Digits After A
Decimal Point That Repeats Further In This
Video We Will Be Looking At This Category
Non Terminating Recurring Decimals We Can Also
Call Them Recurring Decimal Numbers We Will Look At Five Very Simple
Examples
0.666 66 And So On You Would Have Observed That
You  Spend a lot of time writing it You're
not even sure about how many digits you need to put
after the decimal point in true cases We
use a very simple
notation We write it as 0.6 with a bar over the
number These two are equivalent We just
Put a bar over the number that is repeated We may
even put a dot over the number that is
repeated like this
So all the three values ​​are the same but
writing it in one of these ways is a lot
simpler and definitely cleaner. Here's a second
example.
2.77
7777 And so on in this number the part since
is repeated indefinitely so we can write it
as 2.7 with a bar o 7 we can also write it
as 2.7 with a dot over 7 very simple right ok let's
look at an interesting
example now
indefinitely  So we can write it as Let
me make it slightly more difficult The
number is
5.65
327 6532 7 And so on in this example 6
5327 is repeated So we can write it as
5.65 327 with the b over 6532
7 That was simple but how  We Put Dots
Over the Repeating Part 5.65 327 Where Do
I Put the Dots Over the
First and the Last Digits of
the Repeating Part So We  Put dots over 6s
and since this tells us that this is
repeated here is our last example
7.15
2323 23 and so on here
the initial two digits after the
decimal point are not repeated but that is
repeated after that so what do we do about this
part  Simply we don't put a bar and a dot
over it we just ignore it and write it as is it can be
written as
7.15 23 with b over 23 since ts is the only
part which is repeated and how can we
write it in the dot format we  Right
7.15 23 with dots over 2 and
3 ts All You Had to Know About
Representation of Recurring Decimal Numbers The
First Four Examples We Saw a Pure
Recurring Decimal Numbers We Call It Pure Since
All the Numbers After the Decimal Point
Follow a Repeating Pattern Now Look  At the
Fifth Example The First Two Digits Are
Not Part of the Repeating Pattern 15 is Not
Repeated So What Do We Call This Kind of
Recurring Decimal Number No We Don't Call It
Impair We Call It a Mixed Recurring Decimal
Number It's a Mixture of Non Repeating  end
[music]
repeating h